[Música]
olá meu nome é alexandre são do 5º ano
tenho 10 anos ea gente falar um
pouquinho pra vocês sobre diferenças
sociais
como sabemos a maioria dos da sua melhor
prateleiras tenham até dois mil reais
será que vocês família conseguiriam
viver com essa renda
isso leva a grandes diferenças sociais
como mostra nessa famosa fotografia de
tuca vieira como consequência temos uma
elevada taxa de analfabetismo no brasil
saber que 16 milhões de brasileiros não
sabem ler e escrever
agora vou contar uma história real
vitória nasceu em uma família com mais
cinco irmãos e morava na zona norte no
bairro vila nova cachoeirinha
seu pai era motorista de ônibus e sua
mãe a auxiliar de escritório durante a
educação infantil
freqüentou núcleo criativo passo aqui
aos sete anos mudou se para o bairro do
capão redondo onde estudou na escola
municipal de ensino fundamental até 8º
ano
também freqüentou atividades culturais
em associação sem fins lucrativos e e
ficou sabendo da escola comunidade de um
colégio privado por meio de um amigo
a escola da comunidade foi criada em
1966 ela dava educação para a população
de baixa renda
nilce iniciou-se com 36 crianças e 35
adultos
atualmente oferece 1.000 7700 bolsas de
estudos na educação infantil ensino
médio crianças jovens e adultos
ora estudou muito para a prova da escola
mate lp inglesa e redação
cursou o ensino médio na escola da
comunidade e até hoje é bailarina jogo
do grupo coreográfico do porto durante o
2º ano do ensino médio ela e sua turma
se esforçaram muito para prestar o
vestibular e sonhava em ser arquiteta
foi vitoriosa
atualmente cursa o 2º semestre de
arquitetura de uma repúdio uma
reconhecida universidade de são paulo
ela tem bolsa de estudos integral teve
devido ao seu bom desempenho no enem e
prouni para escolher têtu dura porque
gostava de arte obras desenhos e prédios
antigos no futuro
o vitória quer fazer um curso fora do
país fazendo um estágio na sua área e
depois ter seu próprio escritório de
arquitetura essa história mostra como
podemos diminuir as diferenças sociais
por meio da educação dando a
oportunidade a educação como vitória e
aproveitou a oportunidade para modificar
seu futuro como podemos mudar o cenário
brasileiro
podemos disseminar o modelo da escola à
comunidade por meio da adesão de outras
escolas privadas e levando oportunidade
de educação a mulher de que há milhares
de crianças
agora vai recitar um poema diferenças
sociais autoria de deus me deu uma certa
vou descrever socialmente só favelas
intervenções
criamos uma malabaristas apresentando
suas artes nos vermelhos sinais forma
que mata mesas fartas penitenciárias com
presas na armados meninas de pé no chão
brincando com a arma na mão de polícia e
ladrão bombas que cruzam o céu azul
comprometendo a paz o que fazer como
modificar o quadro que aí está
o poeta responde socialmente só pela
campanha pelo conhecimento da educação
pela consciência do coração pela fé na
religião pela caridade que vê no outro
um irmão
assim o mundo será melhor sem fome sem é
ascender socialmente a mãe obrigada